MATTHEW RITGER: The title
of my dissertation is
"Objects of
Correction: Literature,
and the Birth of
Modern Punishment."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADIN CORMACK: I've had the pleasure
of advising Matthew Ritger along
with my colleagues, Leonard
Barkan, Sophie Gee, and Nigel
Smith.
MATTHEW RITGER: I study the 16th and
17th century, which for most people
means either
Shakespeare or Milton.
But I study the way that
literature of that era
was related to the carceral
history of the same era.
BRADIN CORMACK: Matthew is immensely
creative and imaginative.
He's extremely disciplined
as a reader and critic
and historian.
He's voracious in his reading.
MATTHEW RITGER: The beginning of the
idea that you could use work training
and work discipline and
use temporary punishments
as a way of reintroducing
people to the workforce, that
began in this period.
And that began at
these places called
the houses of correction,
and at this place
called Bridewell in London.
So that's Bridewell
palace/prison.
And you can see the
two courtyards that
became the prison
cells, and then you
can also see the long gallery
heading north-south there.
And that long gallery
with the giant windows
was, on the one hand,
the famous aspect
of the palace that would seem
to be so ill-suited to becoming
a prison.
But because they were
creating workshops,
and because there's
no electricity,
and they need the light,
the workshops actually
were in these double-paneled
hall of incredibly tall windows
so that they could
work on their projects
and have the light to do so.
I think when you're a graduate
student, you spend so long just
having to have faith
that your ideas are good,
or that they will be rewarded,
or that the work you do
matters, but that there are
really few opportunities where
someone steps back
and really stands
behind your work in such a way.
And so that feels
baffling and amazing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]